is it too much pressure in a sense to
put out a new record
um well you know this record has been
interesting to put out in general
because it's during
you know a pandemic a
you know racial revolution uh
an election year um i'm delivering a
baby around the same time i mean it's a
lot like i wasn't planning on all that
at all
right i wanted to put the record out in
the beginning of summer but it is a
record about hopefulness and resilience
because it was made during the darkest
time of my life where i was clinically
depressed
i had a a change in
in my career with the last record it
didn't necessarily
um meet my expectations
um but it got me out of this loop
of being like a really desperate thirsty
pop star that felt like they had to be
number one all the time and now
i feel like i can create and be more
dimensional as an artist
and also as a human being was the
unhappiness
clinical device it was more than i it
was more than i had
ever faced in my life i had had you know
bouts of depression before but i had
been able to
you know avoid really falling
into the the really dark
depression did you get medication for it
yeah i was so
ashamed about being on medication
because i was like
i wrote firework do you think you were
working too hard
hard work um not meeting expectations i
had broken up with orlando
um i wasn't getting high off of my own
supply anymore what does that mean i
don't get high on my own supply anymore
you create art and you're excited for it
to be
received by the world and when it's
not received by the world when it's kind
of like no thank you
you're like oh [ __ ] that doesn't feel
good
and or you know i had already i had
already
gotten to the peak of the mountain and
the view was getting
kind of you know redundant would they
put you on
it was like an antidepressant but
mentally i was more stable and then i
was able to come off of
medication which is great um because
i think you and i both know that there
are
amazing tools that you can
um access like for instance
our transcendental meditation which i've
been doing for 10 years and you've been
doing forever
i mean that is like in and of itself is
a is a
is a mind cleaner it's a it's it's an
incredible tool to use
for serotonin um does orlando meditate
oh yeah all the time do you think
orlando
couldn't handle where you go in
depression actually the opposite
he's the only one that can handle it and
that's why we're in this position
he still shows up and he still is not
fazed by it
and that is why he's you know
perfect
you